hi everyone
today we'll talk about what's new with
bigquery ml
and we also have demand based with us to
talk about their usage of
bigquery ml i'm abhishek kashyap
the product manager for bigquery ml and
data q a
and i'm eric i'm a data scientist and
i'll be discussing two ways that
demandbase leverages bigquery ml
my colleague leo bunkel was originally
slated to present with me
he did a lot of the work behind uh this
talk so i'd just like to note that i
will be
presenting his slides on his behalf
thank you eric for being here
we'll start with talking about what's
new
and then eric would talk about
demand-based use cases
with bigquery ml to summarize
we have added new types of models to
bigquery ml
to help you create
many more machine learning models
to address most of the use cases that
you would have
for machine learning in bigquery
specifically
for classification and regression models
we have added the support for creation
of
boosted trees using xgboost
deep neural networks using tensorflow
and automl tables
in terms of other use cases we have
added support for creation of hundreds
of thousands of time series models
with a single sql command and you can
also now create
product recommendation systems using
matrix factorization
for use cases that require online
prediction
you can now export any model created in
bigquery ml
and use it for online prediction in
google cloud ai platform
or your own serving stack
to set the stage i'll spend a minute
talking about bigquery
bigquery is google cloud's enterprise
data warehouse
we have exabytes of data stored in
bigquery and customers are able to run
sql queries on petabytes of data all
this
is enabled by the serverless
architecture of bigquery
and underlying that is the separation
of storage and compute which has
allowed our largest customers to store
more
than 250 petabytes of data in the query
and the largest queries being run are on
five petabytes of data
now this is awesome for data analytics
however when you want to do machine
learning
on this data we see a lot of tasks which
are not really machine learning specific
let's say you create a model in a
notebook or a sample of data
that works well but to create a
production model
we see the need to write etl pipelines
for model creation
and then you also have to do etl
pipelines
for predictions as well now bringing
data to machine learning
carries that list of tasks the bigger
headache however is that all the
governance policies that have been
defined on the data
just go out of the window the second you
export it
and train a model on a vm cluster
outside bigquery
which i'm sure no enterprise likes
we are solving that problem through a
sql interface to machine learning called
bigquery ml
with bigquery ml we are bringing machine
learning to the data itself
through two simple sql commands one
you can say create model and
that would build a model for you
within bigquery and second you can just
say ml.predict to use that model
and get predictions in bigquery all your
features
go into the select statement so you can
very very fast recreate on models by
changing your features
and the model type within that sql
we do automate a lot of standard ml
tasks like split of training and test
data sets
standardization of numeric features and
coding of categorical features
so where the minimum number of lines of
code
you can get a pretty good model and
finally since this happens in bigquery
there is no infrastructure management
and all the governance and access
policies you defined
are automatically applied to these
machine learning workloads as well
to recap we are extending bigquery ml
by support of all these new model types
which should enable you to address most
of the machine learning use cases
you have on bigquery data to give you an
example
with a time series model one of our
developer advocates felipe hoffa
wanted to predict how many stack
overflow tags would be there
for each of those and for doing that
felipe created 15 000 different time
series models
in 20 minutes and each of those is hyper
tuned so we actually ended up
creating 600 000 models within 20
minutes without any infrastructure
management without any data etf
another example of a capability we have
brought on
is addition of automl tables automl
tables
was created to build a best-in-class
machine learning model on structured
data
without any feature engineering and
without having to think
about which network architecture to use
automl tables searches through a set of
architectures
and builds the best possible model for
you automl tables has been available
through
its own ui and now we have added it
as a model type to bigqueryll
so just like you can create an xgboost
model or a logistic regression model
you can now create an automl table
classifier
through the same sql interface and very
easily build it into your data and
machine learning pipelines
now all these are being used
for a set of use cases by many of our
customers
to give you a few examples of the most
popular use cases
let's start with the retail industry the
use cases we are seeing
are creating product recommendation
systems to
send products through emails
which are very personalized for the end
users
calculating the propensity to purchase a
propensity to click
on an asset for each customer and again
using it in marketing campaigns
if you want to forecast demand of a
particular product or category by store
by region
with time series you can now do that in
a single sql command and use it for
better merchandising
and supply chain optimization and the
fourth one
is doing customer analytics
by easily creating customer segments aka
personas
when we look at logistics and cpg the
use cases we are seeing
are estimation of the time a package
will be delivered or when a vehicle will
get somewhere
predictive maintenance prediction of how
much inventory of a product would be
needed at a certain warehouse
for financial services and insurance
on the retail side we are seeing usage
in calculation of customer and tv
which can then underlie all business
decisions for each customer
we can improve the underwriting process
by easily predicting
loan default probability at the time of
receiving an application
you can use bigquery ml for the batch
credit card for
fraud detection pipelines that run
overnight
and finally there are use cases
in anti-money laundering as well where
you can forecast
how many transactions may be stopped
for aml checks the fourth vertical
which is media gaming high tech has use
cases similar to retail
where you want to recommend content
through an app
or on the website or you want to predict
player ltv you want to predict game
difficulty
similarly you may want to predict if
someone is going to subscribe
or if someone is going to churn and take
a marketing action
accordingly now all these use cases
can be solved through bigquery ml
with the new features we have added
to walk you through an example a lot of
our customers
join data from multiple online and
offline sources
and create a customer 360 profile in
bigquery
now this customer 360 profile primarily
contains behavior data transaction data
and demographic data you can now use all
of these together
to create a set of customer segments
right within bigquery by using k-means
clustering and we have customers who are
doing it on hundreds of millions of
customers and once you have those you
can build recommendation systems
in place and run personalized campaigns
to each of these customers again staying
within bigquery
and using bigquery ml for these machine
learning tasks
in terms of pricing if you are a flat
rate customer
or you use flex slots you can use your
slots
as is there is no additional charge each
time you build a model uh we just use
the slots you have already purchased
if we are using automl tables or a model
type which uses cloud ai platform in the
back end
we convert those resources into slots
at price parity if you use bigquery on
demand
the cloud ai platform cost is billed as
a passthrough through bigquery
so there is price priority there as well
for models which are trained natively
like time series matrix factorization
and regression
the pricing is according to the amount
of training data
that you use
with that i'll pass it on to eric
thanks abhishek and thanks to google for
giving us the chance to speak
again i'm eric and i'm a data scientist
at demandbase
i'll be discussing two use cases where
we leverage bigquery ml
the first involves our digital
advertising product which consists of
training a model on massive amounts of
data at scale
and the second use case has to do with
how we took a fairly complicated spark
model
that runs on demand and converted it to
run in bigquery ml
and ended up with quite a bit of savings
both in time and cost
so i'll provide a little more context
for each use case before diving in
and first a little bit about demandbase
we're a late stage startup
we have offices in san francisco seattle
new york and london
we've raised over 100 million in venture
capital we consider ourselves an ai
first company
we process the world's business data to
help marketing and sales organizations
and our customers include over 100
fortune 500 companies
we offer a sas platform for
orchestrating account based marketing
strategies
which includes a targeting solution for
advertising an engagement solution for
site optimization and customization
and a conversion tool to align abm
initiatives with sales teams
we have a strong data science and
engineering team all of whom are quite
active
in the gcp ecosystem
so the first use case i'd like to
discuss involves our targeting solution
which is effectively a b2b digital
advertising platform
we use ai to optimize delivery of
digital media to all accounts in our
customers ad campaigns
we provide full transparency when it
comes to advertising metrics such as
media spend click-through rates
account reach etc which means we're held
accountable to delivering the highest
quality inventory that leads to clicks
engagement conversions and so forth
we process roughly 430 billion options
per month
and we bid on those options around the
clock an average of 50 000 bids per
minute
which means we're bidding on nearly a
thousand auctions every second
so just to give you a sense of the size
of this data again we're bidding on
nearly a thousand requests per second
and each bid request
consists of thousands of features for
example this person here visits her
favorite news site during the day
we know the ip address of the request we
know the company she works for
right down to the location of the office
in geo whatever site she's visiting we
know the publisher the amount of
inventory on that page the position of
the ad etc
and finally there's all kind of
additional data such as the exchange the
type of auction
deal id and so forth on top of all that
we could have dozens of our own customer
campaigns that qualify to serve that
single ad during that visit
so we also need to work out which one to
serve to do so we use a click-through
rate model that essentially takes all
these features
and predicts just how valuable that
option is what the likelihood is that
it'll lead to a click
etc and this scoring and decision making
all has to happen within several
milliseconds for each bid request
so initially we did all our data science
and local jupiter notebooks
meaning we'd export the data out of
bigquery in a python notebook for
analysis
training validation etc and scikit-learn
besides being inconvenient limitations
on the size of the data
cpu memory meant that we had to down
sample the data
not just the number of rows but even the
number of features that were considered
for the model
so it's no surprise with such a high
cardinality of features that this would
affect both the calibration of the model
and its accuracy
since our data already resided in
bigquery we decided to use bigquery ml
namely because it solves these issues
and as i'll show next
training a logistic regression model is
just trivially easy you just point your
model at your training set
no matter how many rows or features and
bigquery ml takes care of one hot
encoding
k-fold cross-validation and everything
else under the hood
so it's much more convenient much faster
and because we no longer had to down
sample rows or features
we actually saw significant improvement
in the calibration of the model and its
performance
so just to show you a real example this
is how you train a logistic regression
model
it's really as simple as writing a short
sql query you can see the table name as
bid request dot training set
you name the model whatever you want in
this case model underscore name
specify the model type logistic
regression in this case
add a parameter for l1 regularization
and that's it
when it's done you save the output just
as you would any table and that table
which is really a model
can then be queried for validation or to
make actual predictions
there are a variety of things you can
control if you want to do multi-class
classification
or if you want to standardize or scale
your features it's all available
so this is what we did this is how we
moved off of scikit-learn and onto
bigquery ml
so what if you want to try a different
model let's say
a deep neural network for example almost
nothing changes except for the model
type
and in this case how many layers you
want other than a physical limitation of
512 megabytes
i believe you can have as many layers
and nodes as you wish
so in this case i specified three layers
with 256 nodes
two more layers with 128 nodes each and
that's it just press enter and wait for
the training to finish
so with deep neural networks you have
similar options as logistic regression
but also one specific to neural networks
such as batch size dropout rate etc we
also tried xg boost
which is sort of the hottest algorithm
around since random for us
again you can see that very little is
changing here same training data set
just a different model type in addition
to parameters specific to xg boost such
as the booster
type it also supports l1 l2
regularization
and other options there's even a boosted
tree regressor if you want to do
regression instead of classification
just change the model type so we've seen
how to train three different models
how do we validate them once they've
been solved
save sorry and the answer is once again
as simple as the sql query
you've saved your model with some name
just select the precision recall
f1 score from that model just as you
would query a table
this makes it very easy to inspect
validation metrics understand future
importance
and what was important to us was being
able to access the coefficients of our
model
what's really cool is that these
validation metrics can also be viewed as
interactive dashboards that are built
right into bigquery ui
so yeah it's very cool stuff and i
should mention that the xg boost model
did have the best f1 score
ever so slightly better than logistic
regression and dnn
overall comparable f1 scores across all
three models
so the second use case is for a solution
we call account selection
basically a customer provides us with
data such as keywords describing their
business
buyer titles or list of existing
customers and we use ai to identify
companies with strong buying signals for
that customer our account selection
model trains on terabytes of b2b signals
and intent data and effectively
generates a ranked list of accounts
that your company should target next
because our customers will prioritize
their entire marketing and sales cycles
with this list of companies
it's incredibly important that we get
this right customers should be able to
update their profiles and relaunch
account selection
which basically trains a new model and
generates a new list of companies for
that customer
the way we initially saw this was to
build the model in spark and use
on-demand clusters
which were not only costly but would
cause issues when the job failed
because a new cluster had to be
provisioned from the marketplace which
increased the time and the cost etc
so a new model has to be trained
whenever a user pushes the button
this means we have to support hundreds
if not thousands of jobs per week
and the cost was something like dozens
of dollars per job
in terms of size the features include
intent keywords company from a graphics
job titles and other b2b signals
basically thousands of dimensions that
we reduce using techniques like matrix
factorization
we previously stored our data in all
kinds of disparate data sources from
postgres to static files in the cloud
in terms of time starting a cluster and
then training the spark model
typically took up to 40 minutes for each
job to complete and when a job would
fail
a new cluster would have to be started
it would occasionally take several hours
for a single job to complete
so along comes bigquery ml we decided to
replace our spock model
our spark random force model with a
logistic regression model in bigquery ml
um this was not without its challenges
for example we had to either move our
data
sets into bigquery or at least copy them
as temporary tables in bigquery
to build the final training table this
means all the feature engineering has to
be expressible as sql statements or udfs
so for example if you use the cosine
similarity between vectors as a feature
you'd have to express that as a query
our approach was to build this pipeline
as a dependency graph
so what do i mean by that basically we
created a data pipeline entirely out of
sql queries in bigquery
organized it into a graph so any
extraction transformations feature
engineering etc
we express as a directed graph that
creates temporary tables at each step
this way if anything were to happen
during the process we wouldn't have to
run the entire thing again
but just pick up from the temporary
tables and then continue to run the
pipeline until we end up with the final
training data set so i've already
covered how to train a logistic
regression model
so i'll just jump to the final output
basically we end up with a rank list of
companies that have greater likelihoods
of becoming a future customer
i do have to note this screenshot was
lifted from our website this is not real
data being shown here
and again because our customer's entire
marketing and sales cycle could be based
around this list
it's essential that decisions made by
the model are explainable
the first thing a customer will want to
know is why did you include this account
because bqml makes it easy to extract
feature weights for each model
we are in fact able to make explainable
statements like well this account is
similar to an existing customer
or has a strong intent for keywords in
your industry or whatever
so for this use case we've been running
the model in bqml for months and we've
had
zero failures which is amazing previous
average times of up to 40 minutes to run
the job now take closer to five minutes
so the time to create a new list for
customers was reduced by a factor of 10.
if you break down the costs and again
we've actually never had any failures
bqml today
the cost is now basically only a few
dollars per job which means a cost
reduction of over 10x
so overall bigquery ml has been a huge
game changer for demandbase
not only improving the accuracy of our
model in the first use case but saving
us a factor of 10x in both time and
money for the second use case
so we absolutely plan on continuing to
leverage bqml
for our next generation of machine
learning models at demandos
thank you very much thank you eric for
your time
and these insights were extremely useful
if you want to learn more we have a
coursera course that would teach you
how to use bigquery ml with some code
labs using quick labs
the use cases that are shared we are
building
template jupyter notebooks which we are
hosting
at the link i'm sharing here and finally
if you decide to use bigquery ml and
have any questions or feedback for
our team please do write to us
thank you for your time and hope you
have a great day